con la muerte de un adolescente de 14
años ya son 46 los palestinos muertos en
2023 por fuego israelí ya sea de
soldados o de colonos judíos en concreto
este menor de llenín recibió un disparo
en el abdomen por parte del ejército
israelí mientras las tropas llevaban a
cabo una redada que como es habitual
desencadenó en enfrentamientos armados
con milicianos locales según el ejército
este operativo tenía como objetivo el
arresto de un sospechoso supuestamente
involucrado en el robo de un cuerpo de
un druso israelí que falleció en un
accidente de coche en noviembre pasado
Sin embargo el ejército no se refirió a
la muerte de este menor que sucede a
otra muerte de anoche la de un joven de
27 años asesinado en un ataque de
colonos israelíes la violencia es cada
vez peor en cisjordania y podría
intensificarse si nos guiamos por las
palabras de Benjamín netanyahu el Primer
Ministro israelí ha expresado un
fortalecimiento de los asentamientos y
anticipado una operación a gran escala
en los territorios palestinos también en
Jerusalén este ocupado aún más
extremista se ha mostrado itamar
benjivir el ministro de seguridad no
solo ha pedido mano dura aquí en
Jerusalén sino que ha ratificado su
intención de aplicar la operación escudo
defensivo 2 en alusión a las operaciones
israelíes de la segunda intifada que
dejaron cientos de palestinos Muertos
Aunque la prensa israelí le ha quitado
hierro a esta declaración a través de un
alto funcionario el ataque del viernes
contra una parada de autobús en el que
murieron tres israelíes dos de ellos
menores los arrestos de palestinos y la
demoliciones de casas entre muchas otras
cosas Sólo incrementan estas tensiones